the first first standards committee
meeting this year
i hope that everyone's well and
surviving in these
difficult times um i'm councillor kevin
proctor and i'm the chair of this
committee
um just a quick reminder to everyone
that this meeting will be filmed
for live and of subsequent broadcast on
council
council's channel traffic council
meetings youtube
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except with our confidential or exempt
items if you make representation
to the meeting you will be deemed to
have consented to being filmed
if you do not wish to have your image
captured or if you have any queries
regarding the webcasting of the meetings
please contact the democratic services
officer
can also please ask that everyone keeps
their microphone muted
unless you are speaking to the meeting
and use the chat facility if you wish to
speak
this avoids any unju echo
and ensures that everyone gets a chance
to speak in order of their
request we've got a fairly short
agenda tonight but we've got two
important items for us
to consider and i hope that we'll have
some
good discussions on on those so moving
forward
onto the agenda attendances um i've had
no apologies
um but we do have a fairly uh strong
showing tonight so that's that's good
but we've actually had no actual
apologies to the meeting
uh item number two minute to the meeting
held on 23rd
september 2020 obviously some time ago
i hope are we happy to agree then
if uh anyone has any comments about that
please
speak now or let me know
otherwise i will accept those as silence
as
uh agreeing those minutes
okay thank you we will move on um
i have no urgent [ __ ] item three urgent
business i have no urgent business at
all been notified to the meeting
so nothing to discuss there
um item 4 is one of the substantial
meeting agenda items that we're going to
be discussing
the lga model code of conduct
um just in terms of background
we did discuss this some in some detail
at our last meeting
but as members will see in the report
the final version was released by the lj
in december
a very comprehensive document i think
you would all agree
there are however some areas of
contention and we're expecting further
guidance this month
which should help us as members will see
we're proposing to include this as part
of the recommended annual review
of the code of conduct the timetable for
this is set out in the report
and includes the proposal to set up a
small short
term working group to give feedback
the committee are there for us to note
the report
agree the proposed actions and timeline
over the next
few months as set out in the report
agree setting up a working group to help
in updating the code of conduct
do you want to add anything effects this
[Music]
jane
it didn't work um yes just to say that
the code is published has not
um varied um significantly from what was
considered
by um this committee prior to the
consultation
and as you mentioned there are still
some areas that require some
verification
and guidance and some which would still
require
um legislation to enable us to actually
be able to put them into place
many of the aspects the code are very
similar to those that we already
have in place business different style
as much as anything in
rather than content or other other than
those areas that we're still waiting for
guidance on
um but you'll know within the report
that it does make reference to the fact
that we are
looking at this on a gm basis so um
when the original model code
came out we did review it um
across the chief legal officers um
across gm
um and um we came up with a
um an agreed model code which was
actually based on one that was drawn up
by
trafford based on the the guidance
but was adopted by um all the
authorities across gm but with local
variances where
um appropriate um and so we're looking
at this again at chief legal officer
level
um we have a meeting uh to look at it
which will uh in two weeks time
um and what i would propose is that the
work
you do on that dovetails with the work
that it will
agree at tonight um is carried out by
the working group
um so that we come up with um a
um a code which we feel happy with from
both the gm perspective but also that
take
to account the traffic um uh view of
things
um and uh then that obviously will be
brought back to
to uh this committee uh for approval
once that work being done
um so unless there are any questions and
uh
yeah that all makes perfect sense i'll
open up for
uh comments and and questions at this
point
uh councillor blackburn has raised her
hand
yes thank you um on uh point uh 2.3
it it it mentions the variations
to to that that's going to be adopted
you know within the you know the gm
authorities
could could you just sort of comment
about what
the variations are likely to include
can't hear jane
sorry i'm having to flick between
screens and
uh and i was looking at the document the
time
i don't have it printed off i only have
a electronic version
then i couldn't find my unmute so um
that they they're
they're very local they tend to be more
around
the way in which um standards dealt with
on a hearing basis
um and and those sorts of things and um
i i i can pick up some examples for you
for
when um when we come back we will i i
can
give you the local variances that may be
um
being considered by other authorities um
they're not significant um they tend to
reflect really character so i think in
terms of
wigan has a few more restrictions in
place which
um uh probably stretch the code a little
bit
at times but then they have an awful lot
of standards
issues then uh they have a lot of
independent members and
uh and there are um
different uh challenges around managing
um
councils in that particular set of
circumstances
so um but what i will do is if there are
any variances that are being picked up
on a local basis
i'll make that we report them back to
you so that you can see what they might
be and whether or not chapter feels that
that that they are relevant or
appropriate in those circumstances
yeah could i ask one one other thing
kevin
yeah um just just reading through um
20 to the local authorities agreed
20 said they were gonna have bits five
percent hadn't reviewed it but 55
we're not going to adopt the code um
what's your take on that well they do
have to have some
some form of code they can't have no no
no um but they're not very high
percentage
that's slightly slightly surprising to
me that percentage
yeah that's just just in the paper yeah
yeah it may be just that they're not
pressing to adopt it
as it stands in its entirety and as i
say we would not
adopt that code um
in its entirety we would look to um uh
review it and to uh trafficize it before
we actually
put it into place quite right thank you
it's mike by the way it's not uh it's
not it's not sue yes
okay i don't know in the background i
think last time alex was able to change
that to mike but uh don't worry
no worries a question um arose really
was
a couple of meetings ago uh jane was
putting together
a spreadsheet in relation to best
practice that was being worked through
i don't think we ever concluded that is
this now superseding that
there are i think the elements that we
hadn't concluded were the elements
around consulting with the parish
councils
into with a particular aspect of it in
terms
of um the our code and the review of it
and that will actually take that that
that is actually something which will be
part and parcel
of what we will do um in terms of this
review and implementing the code so
though
i think the i think that was the
principle what aspect that was
outstanding
and the others were linked to the model
code and so they will
as a as you quite rightly say be
um brought within the the the review and
the implementation of the the new code
uh but what i will do is i'll ask uh
alex to make sure that we just
review that table and make sure that
there wasn't anything else but
i and my understanding was i think there
were only a couple of matters and they
were all
linked to the um adoption and
implementation
of a new code
could i just ask chair one other
question kindly
thank you um only in relation to the
content of um
this uh document that's come out and
if there are any issues that we may have
will we feed those into
our own working group um or
is that for this meeting now to discuss
do you want to take that or do you want
me to
i'll let you thank you
thank you um so um i i i think that if
we set up the
the working group then the idea would be
that you would feed in any comments
to the to the working group um and then
we will make sure that those are all
captured
and reported back to this committee more
generally when we do
uh finally report back on the um
with our proposals around the code thank
you
um i'm not seeing any more
people asking for raising their hands or
questions you know the other questions
um just just on the the working group
when when we will be asking for the
volunteers jane
is that now or
soon when when do we cry and presume we
need a bit of a mix of
counsellors and independent members on
that that working group which was
probably
good and necessary
sorry i was just checking the paper
again on the recommendations and the
timeline so
um yes so um i i
would suggest that rather than having
everybody
put their hands up now probably if you
could submit
a an expression of interest to alex in
the first place
and then we will manage that and look at
um how we set it up
so in doing so there is a timeline set
out in the
um report and obviously we would need to
be able to work within those parameters
so
um if you're going off on a very long
holiday or something like that
which would be very nice if that was the
case but but yes they just basically be
mindful of that
um put forward
um put yourselves forward if you're
interested and then we will
um have a talk to you chair
and and and if that's
if that would be an acceptable way to
you to proceed
way forward yeah yeah hopefully we will
have enough people to
make it uh work effectively and and get
to get good feedback that we need yeah
have we any idea on the numbers
and the mix of the people we need on the
working group um how many councillors
how many independents
so on i have no idea well
probably i'd say we need how many
it's up to us to decide or yourself
uh with consultation with jane to decide
yeah we'll talk it through but i think
we need a minimum of like
three three of each i think
i think it's really a matter of having a
coalition of the
willing here as much as anything um
and so um it wouldn't be required to be
politically
balanced but it would be useful to have
representation
from across the board so um uh but i
don't i think if you say three of each
you're probably going to end up with
most of the committee
as well so i i i it it needs to be
a small and quite a nimble group i think
for the purpose
yeah okay but so if we ask first
questions
we will we'll we'll review it at that
point if that's okay
yeah thank you okay
any more questions comments no
okay well thank you for that we're
making good progress on that one and uh
i can see a a good way forward and
we we will meet the timetable i'm sure
uh moving on to the
next item which is member development
um i remember we'll see the report
a review of the training has recently
taken place which reported back to the
cross party
member development steering group to try
and make training
more accessible effective and relevant
and increase take-up which is critically
important
um it has been relatively low i think
in the council for quite a long period
of time
uh this has led to a number of proposals
to improve take-up
these include
a regular scheduled training slot
a core training pathway member
development schedule
and the development of a training tag
mark stroke logo
for those who have completed the core
training program
i'm also looking updating the current
internet pages which i think would be
really helpful as well um we've
therefore asked to the
agreement recommendations set out in the
report
um that's the the basis of it do you
add anything to that jane
no uh really no chair other than to say
that
training's not necessarily
one of the key areas that comes within
the standards
committee remit but i think it is very
important because i think
that members um knowledge and
understanding
um both of their uh roles and how
the the the the council works but also
in
the the more sort of um
specialized areas that they might also
wish to follow training on it
is very important and can help very much
in terms of um ensuring that they are
able to
represent um people
effectively um and and so um we thought
it was
in it it was useful for the standards
committee to
have some oversight as to what uh
training
um was available and was being offered
and uh
we felt also that it would be useful
to put some measures in place which
would encourage
um greater take up um and also
enable um the public to have some
uh indication as to um the the
their representatives take up of the
training offer
that is available so um that is why this
of package has been put together it has
been through the member development
group which is a cross-party group
which meets regularly and has been uh
soundly endorsed by the member
development group
yeah thank you um i personally am very
supportive of these like they're
really good good suggestions i think
they will work uh but we've got a
question from
uh hartley
thanks uh chair yeah i i think it's
really good uh
the proposals are really good i like the
idea of doing the
the core training before the council
meetings i think that will
uh really help with with take-up um
so i was just just looking at the the
annex
um which has got the the various
training modules listed in it at page
30 um and i just want to check
that that what what's being suggested is
the
so the core modules that start sort of
halfway down there starts with
value-based recruitment
value-based recruitment um and so
there's only those
two there's only those two sessions that
seem to be in person the rest
like they're e-learning so i'm just
wondering what which of those modules
are the ones that will be covered at the
at the sessions before the council
meetings
because apart from the induction there's
only seems to be those two that
that are not e-learning just want to you
know check them understanding that
alex correctly really
so um at the moment the the what that
next shows is those modules which are
currently available
online um in terms of the pre-council
um sessions we would look to develop a
program
for that in conjunction with the
um development
team at the hr development team um who
will have access to
programmes and we'll also look at
developing our own in-house
uh learning programmes there um
so we don't have that um as yet and
that's something that would be
in addition it covered some of the core
modules
uh but it may also cover additional
measures the same crop up as it were
and and obviously we're always
interested
to hear if members have specific areas
where they feel that
training needs could be supported
and those needs can be fed in either
through the member development group or
directly
directly through this committee or to
myself that would be fine
and check could i ask another question
uh oh yeah mma
there's so it's just well i suppose it's
just a sort of a plea really or a
request around the
so the new member induction sessions
i seem to remember when i so i was
elected nearly two years ago and
remember when i went on them there were
councillors there in fact i think
councillor coggins and some other people
nicole might have been at smurf sessions
so i just wanted to check that it would
be possible to to operate those sessions
to all members
because i i wasn't able to make it to
all of those and
um or i suppose offer alternatives
because it seems to be
you know you missed you missed the one
session and it and it's gone so
um you know i'll be waiting two years i
guess to do it again so yeah it's just
to see if there's some
uh way for members to to go on those or
to run a couple of alternative sessions
for those
i mean obviously this year we're still
in the position where we
don't know where we will where we will
be um
in terms of being able to do things in
person or whether they'll be done
virtually a at that point
uh sorry the class decided to join us
um uh but um we we will be
looking to ensure even if we're
doing them in person we're looking to
record all training sessions so that
they will be available
to members subsequently um or
in their own time if they're not able to
make um
the sessions when they are listed and
we're
going to do the same with the
pre-council sessions
um we would look to record those so that
they could be available to members
um who are not able to actually attend
um at the allotted time
uh so yes the key thing is to make
training as easily accessible to members
as possible um to encourage
maximum take-up thank you that's really
helpful thank you chair
okay i've got a question from uh council
blackburn
yeah thank you um every counsellor
is a corporate parent and yet i feel
that there are a lot of counsellors
though
that know nothing or very little
about children in care and the
responsibilities
of of us as corporate parents and
i feel that something like that should
be
included in the training package
i think it's quite important really
because you know it is something that
i don't think has has ever been um
sort of dealt with um you know within
the within the training package of
for trafford personally that's a good
point that
i think we need to feed that through to
the um
development steering group and uh make
sure that they're
aware of that i think it's a it's very
important that they
you know we as councillors we have that
awareness
so it's a good point
and i've got uh councillor
coggins thanks chair um yeah i just want
to ask i asked the other day
about the long-awaited carbon literacy
training for
members and others and i was told that
it was coming from members and it would
be
on tonight's agenda which which it isn't
now i see that it's a bit more
general what we've got here um does
anyone
know this is coming in some other route
is this part of the
it's not listed as part of the core
training i say
um so i suppose yes just looking for
info on on that
fred i don't have any information on
that sir
jane um other than the fact that it
came up at um a corporate leadership
team it was mentioned today in terms of
bringing that board and i understand
that it is all
in hand but i can't say anything i don't
have the precise details around it i
will find out for you
uh council collins and and let you know
but i understand that it's something
that was being pushed both
for corporate leadership teams and
officers as well as for
the members so it was a program as i
understand it i've i've find out there
for you for certain
all right thank you okay
got a question from uh miss jackson
uh thank you i note that
you refer to the training as being
called training
rather than mandatory training um
however i'm aware that some authorities
make training on
licensing and regulation and planning as
mandatory in the sense that um
members are not allowed to sit on those
committees until they've had that
training because of the
quasi-judicial nature of them and
it has any thought being given to that
or is is that the actual practice that
trafford
dad do you want me to answer that yes
please
yes so so the position is that we do
have
um requirements for training in respect
of those
quasi-judicial functions and it is the
case that they
uh that normally members are not allowed
to sit until they've completed their
training or at least they've had
some training that enables them
sufficiently to do it but they you know
if we
have an emergency situation but for
example even the substitutes are not
permitted
unless they have the necessary training
okay we have a question from councillor
myers
yeah thank you chairman um my concern
really
is over the proposal that to run some of
these sessions before the council
meeting
uh when we have um uh
real i don't know how you describe it
but a non-virtual meeting we're actually
in the council chamber
um very often there's there's uh
uh it's quite a busy a busy affair we
start at 6 30 nearly always goes on to
sorry start at seven nearly always goes
on to 9 30.
no matter who the mayor is it seems
impossible to end them any sooner than 9
30.
and if we're going to start at 5 30 and
more or less with one break
run through for four hours that seems
like a long time to me
i don't know how useful it would be the
other problem for me personally is
getting there
and if i'm going to be physically in the
council chamber i just about normally
make it for seven o'clock
uh following work and uh it's just very
difficult so i think there might be a
lot of people who can't actually make
that time
thank you yeah i think i think you're
right there will be some people who
that's just not
not viable for but there's the others
who will suit
quite well i mean i appreciate the
length of time that they'll be in the
council meetings but um yeah it will
suit some people and others it won't do
so i think it's probably
one of these things that you you try and
see how it works really and
hopefully make some amendments and make
some concessions
to things so yeah that's a
good good point thank you uh can i just
uh
come comment there chair sorry um uh the
the proposal is that they're done from 5
30 till 6 30 so there would be a
break because it recognizes that there
are various things that need to
happen before council meetings as well
but the other proposal is that they will
be recorded
and so if members are not able to attend
they will be available on the website
so that members can um
see the slides and or you know
participate in it
pick up on on the key points of the
training in that way
um so uh yeah we are as i say very keen
to do this but it was felt that it would
be
a useful thing to have that regular slot
um and partly to encourage attendance
but also to encourage people to put
forward idea
ideas for training as well if they felt
that there was a slot that
that would be available to for that
purpose
yeah thank you
scenario for training there's going to
you're always going to be some people
who
it's going to suit and others it's not
so i think you know well
then the reasonable number of people who
will suit personally
um and others there are ways around that
i think so
yeah with a bit of flexibility i think
we can get there
with the with the training can i just
say yeah chairman i
i made the assumption that we're trying
to be more interactive than that perhaps
but if it's just visually watching
slides and listening to a presentation
it's fine okay thank you
hopefully the actual in-person events
will be more interactive but there are
ways to make at least the the the
the essence of the training available
but yes the idea is
for those sessions to be um more
um more interactive than the
uh ones that you get just through the
online training
okay uh did we have a question from
mr griffiths um
yeah i just wanted to say that i thought
this was a very good initiative and i
think it ought to be
um developed um especially the idea of
evidence
um i think that would act both as a
stimulus for
other counsellors to uh to do it but
also i think it looked good for the
outside
you know if you can show that to the
general public to the electorate that
that's what the training is taking
place and being taken up i think that's
an extremely good
uh a good thing um the only other thing
the comment really is that i hope uh
this isn't
when you're developing these training
packages it's not reinventing the wheel
i just i wonder what other you know
other authorities are doing and
whether there's anything you can pinch
from them from similar initiatives
um i'm sure the human development
steering group will be looking at those
those kind of things and tailoring
packages that best
meets those needs with you know easy
outcome for
the participants so i think thank you
for those comments
and chair on that can i say that we do
um uh
work um closely with the lga program as
well
so you know we are picking up ideas
where where we can
um we do um trade ideas across
greater manchester we have a strong um
uh
monitoring officers group which is good
at
exchanging ideas so yes uh
we we're we we are not at all
uh backwards in coming forwards in terms
of accepting good ideas when we see them
yeah i could could i make a point um
about the gdpr training um
we did it some time ago because
obviously the legislation came in about
four years ago was it um so i did the
course some time ago but i keep
getting bombarded with emails saying
that i haven't done the training
but there's no way of replying to them
can i just say cancer john and that's
because it's an annual requirement and
you are required to do that training on
an annual basis
why are you keep getting yourself no one
to ask
um so it doesn't change every year then
um
it's updated on an annual basis but you
do
need to you do need to carry out that
training on an annual basis
and your group should be communicating
that
to you because we actually get a return
on who's completed it and who
i only get the emails but there's no way
of replying because there are no reply
emails which
is no no fine okay there's no way of
asking the question
so i i will have a
i will raise it with your with with the
groups i think perhaps we'll send out a
general
reminder to the groups because um it is
something that your
whips should be making sure that you're
asked me about it i thought somebody
would have sort of
yes asked me why he hadn't done it if it
was supposed to be done but
okay all right that's important that's
that is a mandatory training course
annual thing i've tried about five times
and
i still can't log on to get onto it so
if somebody could arrange to send me
a link can i
cancel back when you con i'll send you
the details but is neil
meehan in the hr
team he will be able to sort that out
and i will mention it to him okay
yes thank you thank you
um we had a question from counselor new
gross i think you may be withdrawn that
is that right
it was it was the definition between
mandatory and
uh when you said flexibility would be
given it's just that i mean
many of my group work nine through five
thirty
they wouldn't be able to get to that pre
um council
training if they wanted to uh as long as
we've got the flexibility
and we can provide it in other ways i
i'm i'm okay with that
oh good right thank you
okay we've had quite a reasonable
discussion on that there's any
any announcement to make any comments
questions
no okay well thank thank you for your
uh participation in that and uh
your questions i think we've had some uh
very useful pointers there about how to
improve training for for counsellors
uh moving on to monitoring office report
um over to james over again
well chair on on this one there's
there's probably not much to say because
what everything we've got is is is
covered within um
obviously the um the review is a code
uh of conduct um and
that sort of picks up the the matters
that were coming through
um uh the previous committees as
um mike whiting uh
picked up those were the other
outstanding uh
issues um the position
um across trafford um remains
members have been obviously very very
much engaged
through the pandemic i think it's been a
very um
difficult and challenging time for both
members
and obviously residents but members have
risen
to the challenges of virtual
meetings um and ensuring that they
are still able to uh represent their
um constituents very effectively
um we um as you know in trafford have a
very
low um level of um
complaints um and uh we still only have
the one
uh complaint which is currently being
reviewed
um uh so in that respect
um i have to uh commend and thank all
members
uh for their uh behavior which
generally uh is um
very very um compliant in terms of the
um the the the code um
and normally does not cause me a lot of
of issues so i'm very pleased to be able
to to report on that
i think um there are going to be
challenges
uh going forward obviously we go into
pre-election period now where
um people become slightly more
tense in the way in which uh things are
played out but again say we generally
have
a very civilized way of proceeding
through that and i would hope that that
remains the
remains the case um going forward as we
develop the code of conduct i think
there will be more interaction with our
parish councils
because that's necessitated both in
terms of the review but also in terms of
the way in which we operate um going
forward
um so i suppose really for my report i
would just like to say
thank you to yours we come to the end of
this municipal year and
move into the period for elections to
thank you all for your um
support to to me um in my role as
monitoring officer i'd like to say a big
thank you to our independent
uh persons um as well who um
are a very valuable asset to um
this uh group and um just wish you all
the best
for the next and look forward to seeing
you again in the new
municipal year thank you general like to
echo that and i think the continued low
level of cases hopefully means that we
will do something right anyway and
there's a
hopefully there's a good i think there
is there's a good culture in terms of
you know conduct by councillors i think
it's generally
you know a high standard that we we
operate at it
is my view and i think the you know the
low level
of cases does just demonstrate that
compared to maybe some other authorities
so
it's all good but we can always improve
and i think the
you know the things we talked about this
evening will will help us do that
so any questions for
anybody on jane on that
yeah okay then well
thank you everybody for your attendance
and and contributions
um that concludes the meeting our next
meeting is scheduled for 23rd of june
i'm not sure at this point whether we'll
actually be physically meeting at that
at that time um hopefully at some point
in the future we will do but
uh we've done about the 23rd of june
we'll have to wait and see about that so
once again thank you for your attendance
and contributions
and good evening okay goodbye
thank you